le liban encore et toujours au bord de
l'implosion
malgré l'appel de détresse samedi
dernier du premier ministre par intérim
hassan diab pour pousser son successeur
saad hariri a formé un nouveau
gouvernement
aucune réponse qui permettrait au pays
de sortir la tête de l'eau n'a été
apportée l'équation est claire nous ne
pouvons pas résoudre la crise sociale
sans trouver une solution à la crise
financière nous ne pouvons pas résoudre
la crise financière sans reprend les
négociations avec le fmi nous ne pouvons
pas poursuivre les négociations avec le
fmi sans entreprendre de réformes et
nous ne pouvons pas mener de réformes
sans former un nouveau gouvernement
ces derniers jours la monnaie s'est
effondré de plus de 80 % et la livre
libanaise s'échangeait sur le marché
noir à plus de 10000 livres contre un
dollar une situation dramatique qui
contraint désormais une grande partie
des libanais à passer par des banques
alimentaires pour se nourrir le dollar
vaut désormais dix mille livres
libanaises je ne peux pas trouver de
l'aide pour mon fils ma voiture ne
marche plus et je ne peux pas la réparer
mon salaire vaut désormais 150 $ qu'est
ce que je peux dire de plus je ne peut
plus nourrir ma famille à la fin du
moins la crise de 2019 a été la cause de
milliers de suppressions d'emplois et
autant de comptes en banque gelé depuis
plusieurs jours les libanais manifestent
dans les rues pour dénoncer leurs
conditions de vie et le silence dans
lequel sans murs la classe politique
avec des pneus enflammés les
manifestants bloquent les grands axes de
la capitale beyrouth dans un pays au
bord de l'effondrement économique mais
sans dirigeant politique depuis sept
mois
le patriarche maronite béchara boutros
raï en appelle à l'onu pour aider le
pays à sortir de la crise un recours
vivement critiqué par le hezbollah
chiite qui craint une ingérence
américaine et européenne au liban
un avis que certains des manifestants ne
partagent pas tous les problèmes du
liban sont à cause des armes du
hezbollah
la fin l'argent le terrorisme le vol
tout cela c'est à cause du hezbollah
nous devons nous en débarrasser je ne
suis pas ici à cause de la livre
balèze qui est désormais à dix mille
mais à cause du hezbollah pour le moment
aucune réponse politique n'a été
apportée aux revendications du peuple
libanais le pape françois dont le séjour
en irak s'est terminée lundi a annoncé
vouloir se rendre dès que possible au
liban